In this lesson, we will cover the design of
big, fast, modern routers. Here's a picture of two modern
router chassis. On the left, we have a picture
of the Cisco CRS-1, and on the right, we have
a picture of the Juniper M320. The M320 has,
for some time, been used at the border of the
Georgia Tech network between Georgia Tech and the rest of
the Internet. Here's a picture of a couple of line
cards that go into these chassis. These kind of
look like network interface cards, except the ports are
special, instead of terminating ethernet, these ports terminate high
capacity fiber links. As you can see, these cards
are actually a whole lot bigger than your typical
network interface card as well. And, as a result,
these chassis are often anywhere from three to six
feet tall, and can fill up an entire rack.
There's a significant need for big, fast
routers. Links are getting faster. Traffic demands are
also increasing, particularly with the rise of demanding
applications, such as streaming video. Networks are getting
bigger too, in terms of the number of
hosts, routers, and users. So there's a perennial
need to design big, fast routers, particularly in
Internet backbone networks. The rest of this lesson
will focus on how a router works, in particular,
how it goes from the process of taking a
packet as input and sending it on to where
it needs to go. The Internet's routing protocols, of course,
are responsible for populating the forwarding tables on a
router. But once those tables are populated, the router still
has the hard job of taking a packet as
input and ultimately getting it to the appropriate output port,
so that the traffic can proceed and route to the destination.